hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the webinar today on a very
exciting topic that is spaceomics
that is dedicated to the study of omix
data to study molecular mechanisms
affected by the space travel and
critical for astronaut health as well
so as we have a lot of new participants
joining us today i would like to first
of all introduce what space omix is all
about and then we listen to the mentors
discussing about the various research
project opportunities in the domain
itself
so astrobiology is a science which
addresses the origin of life on earth
and potential for life elsewhere in the
universe as well
space flight is one of the most extreme
conditions that has been encountered by
humans
and advances in omix methodology such as
genomics transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics have revealed that unique
differences exist between individuals
these differences can be amplified in
extreme conditions such as space flight
a better understanding of individual
differences may allow us to develop
personalized counter measure packages
that optimize the safety and performance
of each astronaut
radiation microgravity altered
atmospheric gas composition isolation
and diet changes are just some of the
known stressors affecting humans in the
space environment
with extended mission durations and
distances outside of the earth's orbit
these factors are expected to increase
there are several adverse human health
effects associated with space flight
including bone demineralization skeletal
muscle atrophy cardiovascular
deconditioning vestibular control immune
system suppression and neuro ocular
ailments as well so it is critical to
understand how space flight factors
affect human health in order to develop
space a safe and effective counter
measures
the nasa twin study catalyzed the need
for more comprehensive consortium-based
approaches to study the long-term
effects of space flight on humans here a
nine research group studied a single
data type in detail which another group
performed multi-org synthesis uh to
determine the whole body changes the
study identified alterations in numerous
data types including telomere length
gene regulation gut microbiome
composition body weight carotid artery
dimensions and serum metabolite profiles
as well
so before we start with the talk i would
like to introduce us we are a u.s based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission here is
to make bioinformatics more accessible
our mixed logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
as well adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world
my name is sunali khari and i'm the
omixlogic community manager i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our bioinformatics community managed by
biotech
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets
and develop independent projects that
showcase what has been learned in the
context of a personal portfolio of
projects
as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own
so together with our existing modules
for which you will gain access to the
omixlogic portal where you can try and
explore these modules exercises and
pipeline building coding and various
methods of analysis using projects or
resources from peer-reviewed
publications
now i would like to pass on the stage to
subrajeed bharwan delara dicken to talk
about their astrobiology projects and
experience as well
suprajet barua is an ms in molecular
biology and biotechnology at the
international scam laboratory itamo
university saint petersburg russia he is
a graduate of red school 2021 latex
french exobiology society he is an
astrobiology educator at art of inquiry
where he works closely with julia
brodsky former nasa iess astronaut
trainer he is also a volunteer at mars
on earth project where he works on
margin projects he is a russian
government open door scholar and a
president scholarship awardee as well he
was also one of the top 10 students
globally selected for sgac space health
risk symposium london 2021
we are pleased to have you with us
subrajeet over to you
thank you so much
for that wonderful
presentation
and hello to everyone who has joined